it's nice to meet you so nice to meet  you that was hilarious the clip is  just such a fun cast to work with it's  so much fun yeah it's crazy i i have to  pinch myself all the time because  i'm like it feels like tv royalty that i  get to work and  yeah i feel like you just laugh on set  probably all day long yeah all the time  i'm always the first person to break too  i'm always like i keep it together oh my  gosh  i i'm not good at that yeah i had to do  snl and i was like how am i supposed to  not laugh right now that's not like once  they're trying to make you laugh yeah  yeah these are funny you're gonna laugh  yep i'm still here  just waiting for you to subscribe if you  don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever  help